hello it's funny because you can't even
see him behind that spit C I want to sit
on your lap mommy mommy what are we
doing Mommy hello everyone and thank you
so much for watching this week's podcast
jna and Julie and fugas that's right
we're a little late this week we've been
uh pretty swamped trying to find a new
place oh my God I'm dying and that's why
it look so super extra are [__] hot
today or what
oh I've literally just been staring at
that computer screen all day just
writing emails back and forth and back
and forth and back and forth and back
and forth yeah we have to move out of
this place by the 15th of October it is
now the
5ifth we're cutting it mad close yeah
but we we found a couple places that we
could live in yeah so we're trying to
just close the gap and finish it up yeah
but there's one place place that we do
want to live in yes but this guy's
trying to nickel and dime me all these
people just think I was born [__]
yesterday like I'm some idiot yeah not
I'm not an idiot not an idiot I'm not
it's a good thing that we fight back
though so we don't get taken advant yeah
well what happened is um I just emailed
a lawyer my lawyer my lawyer that helps
me do the things when I'm like help me
I'm an idiot what did the lawyer say
well he said well he said he's going to
help me negotiate because um because the
rent that we pay now is more expensive
than the place that we're living in and
we had to disclose that I think this
guy's really just trying to take me a
ride to try and get as much money as he
can up front so sorry just to correct
you the rent that we pay now is more
expensive than the place we're looking
at correct yeah so he's he's like oh
yeah well I need a pet deposit I'm like
okay that's fine we going to do that
he's like okay well now I need uh an
extra sum of money per month per pet and
I'm like I'm like bro come on what's the
pet deposit for then right exactly I'm
like they're they're tiny little pet
yeah no that he's like okay well they're
going to pay rent too and I'm like what
are we just making up rules as we go
along and then the the the real kicker
was we are going to sign a one-year
lease which is standard and he was like
uh you know you can keep your your this
rate of rent and whatever and then if
you want to renew uh you can't it's only
it goes to month to month or if you want
to sign another one your lease your rent
increases 5% and I'm like blow me like
blow me there's just no reason it's just
pure purely trying to get everything was
going fine every he ran our credit like
everything's good and then all of a
sudden he's like okay well just uh just
pay me for this and pay me for that and
pay for this and I'm like okay this is
that time of this negotiation where I
email a
lawyer [__] yeah I mean it's good it's
good that we're fighting back and I
think in in the end we're we're not
we're not going to just sign off on
something that no and he he was really
trying to get me to do it too he was
like oh just meet me at the [__]
place later today and like bring your
cashier check and I'm like [__] slow
your roll homie yeah so we're trying to
we're trying to get the right place but
do it right at the same time yeah um but
yeah hopefully we'll get a place that's
not shitty and we can shoot videos in
pay rent and the dogs don't need to pay
rent I've never heard of that a monthly
dog fee heard a pet deposit me too cuz
that's a thing right but every month per
pet I mean come on and then he was like
I'm cutting you a deal I'm cutting it in
half cuz they're small dogs yeah okay
you're [__] deal I don't know anybody
that pays rent for their pet pays rent
like that's insane right like you're
telling me if they were cats that you
would charge them rent too what if I had
a hamster does my hamster have to charge
does he owe rent as well what about if
you have a fish tank then you're
[__] oh man that's like what is it
like $15 per fish what if the fish start
inbreeding then you're just going to
lose all your money just totally you
think the landlord would come check on
how many fish you have like every day
unannounced that's a fair play yeah I
know he would count like their eggs too
and he's like kaching kaching kaching
kaching that's the future that's what
this guy's going to do yeah but as I
mean as soon as he started saying some
of these things plus like not all the
appliances are in there we do have to
get some shitty stuff from Craigslist
because that's just how it's going to
happen but I'm like bro come on like
yeah we're not buying a place here we're
renting it help me
yeah you know we were the first people
to bite at this property so he might
feel like oh let's let's let's see what
we can get away with but um that's not
going to happen because I'm a nice
person and people think that just cuz
I'm nice then they can just you know
take me for a ride and I've had it I've
had it sort of like when you were um
when you were supposed to meet uh me at
the house this last week and you were at
the dentist and you kept telling them
that you had to go oh my God I I like
nothing against this woman because I
went to the dentist I've gone like a
bunch of times now I got my wisdom teeth
out and then uh I had originally gone in
because parts of my like not your front
teeth but the ones right next to them
are fake cuz they're not those actual
teeth they're actually my canines cuz I
was born without the adult one of them
so they pulled it and they moved all the
other ones forward and they put like a
composite there so that it looks like
the tooth that it's not but the last
time I had it done I was like 16 years
old so they're Matt old and like you
know a little bit yellow but they what
can happen is that because it's so like
microscopic between the composite and
your actual tooth you can get like
cavities under the composite if they're
old um so I was getting concerned I'm
like they're getting kind of weird Brown
looking and like it looks like there's
stuff in my teeth sometimes you know
what I mean so um and one of them hurt
one day I was like that's not good um
but he they said that they're fine but
that was the original original reason I
went in there and like seven visit
[__] later we're still not there yet
because the dentist you know this is La
so they sort of tell you what to do do
cosmetic wise and he's like all right
we're going to whiten your teeth and
then once it's at a shade that you like
you know we're going to Max the
composite and blah blah blah we're to
redo them and you know after he pulled
my [__] wisdom teeth out I'm like
dying so they whitened my teeth and it
was honestly one of the most painful
[__] things ever it hurts so bad I
I've seen you in a lot of pain and I've
seen you deal with a lot of [__] that
hurts but I've never seen you as upset
and as in agony as you were over well
yeah I was I was frustrated I was sort
of frustrated with a girl that wasn't
[__] speaking English to me she was
like well you're need to come back in 2
weeks but then like if it's a shade that
you like then 3 weeks but then you know
maybe give us a call in 3 weeks for two
weeks and my teeth are just like it
feels like someone's stabbing you and
just oh it's like Crest White Strips
times a billion you know what I mean
like you ever get sensitive oh my God
but it was like so she had her teeth
bleached yeah okay yeah I mean at this
point I drank iced coffee and [__]
whatever else I'm going to eat I'm like
who the [__] cares man they don't need
to be blinding white all right I'm a
human being you're not a coach on The
Biggest Loser yeah seriously like they
all have such white teeth what the heck
oh I just really don't care enough for
them to be like Crystal white you know
plus when they're all they're two we
it's almost like a distraction it's like
it takes away yeah it looks weird weird
you know so it was like the most painful
thing ever and I had already been there
for 3 hours they didn't tell me what we
were going to do that day they they told
me they were just going to check on my
wisdom you know now holes the surgery
and make sure that everything was fine
and uh so the do the dentist comes in he
looks at me he's like yeah they're great
so uh we're going to move on with the
plan I'm like I don't know what's the
plan like what are we doing I don't know
and he's like well we're going to bleach
your teeth today and I'm like [__] man
all right like let's do it 3 hours later
I'm sitting with this woman who's just
giving me the most unclear directions
I'm like lady do you have like a sheet
with this typed up that you can hand out
to people like this is the most unclear
thing I've ever heard of and she's like
giving me this little box full of like
things and like gel and like oh my God
and so I'd already been laying down you
know in complete silence with nothing
but my own thoughts in the dentist's
office for 3 hours and we had to go cuz
we had to go find an apartment yeah and
uh we needed to see that place that day
we had to get mad far away from here and
uh I'm like I got to go and she goes
okay yeah all right um okay but do you
want to go one more session do you want
to keep bleaching your teth teeth cuz
you know sometimes people do four
sessions even though I had done three 15
minute ones with total of 45 [__]
minutes sitting with some orange goggles
on the light I'm like no no no no no no
my teeth are already killing me I'm
already dying there's no way in hell I
want to do it for a session and I
already told you I got to go but thank
you for taking me seriously not so then
she you know gives me more unclear
directions I keep going I got to go I
got to go she every time she would go
okay no I hear you all right yep uh-huh
okay well here's this this here's a you
know here's your tray for in case you
want to WIP your teeth some more and I'm
like can I tell you the last thing I
ever want to do is WIP my teeth again
like this has been the most miserable
thing ever maybe I have really sensitive
teeth or something no but this this
comes back to the fact that you're a
nice person and when you're nice and
when you're Pleasant and when you go out
of your way uh you know naturally
subconsciously to make things smoother
to make people feel comfortable around
you sometimes and often times in
settings like this they take advantage
and they don't DET yeah well it's not
even your fault I'm just saying like the
way people react is they don't listen to
what you're saying because you are
making such a good effort at making them
feel okay and comfortable in a situation
so they don't really you know when they
when you say I have to go they're like
okay you know well well yeah you're
being so nice they're never going to
snap at me so I'm just going you know
what I mean this is a nice person why
would I ever you know what I mean be in
trouble with him so I think that's kind
of how that goes you you've experienced
that in more than one facet of your life
but oh like all the time yeah so I I get
frustrated because when I'm with you and
I see this happening I'm like on the
third party you know standpoint seeing
you being so nice and this person
clearly taking advantage of how graceful
you're being it just makes my blood boil
because you're like okay dude you know
what I mean figure it out this person's
nice but don't just ignore them it's
making me crazy and I can tell it's
making you crazy it's making me crazy
and when I'm not there obviously I canot
control it so to see you so upset sucked
but well that that like I was so upset
like I was crying like I was miserable
it was a combination of that and then
the stress it was a combination of a lot
of things and I know a lot of people
think that I'm like a take zero [__]
type of person cuz I do come off that
way and I am that way in a lot of ways
but when it comes to dealing with other
people I have a really hard time
standing up for myself sometimes you
know what I mean absolutely or like
being assertive or being taken seriously
especially since you know I am friendly
and I am nice so especially in this like
a negotiation in terms of like your rent
or you know what what is fair because
that's all I ask do you know what I mean
like I understand understand a pet
deposit like I understand a lot of
things and I will be amicable in this
conversation of of reaching a compromise
but like this guy is just like oh yeah
okay each uh each pet you know each fish
that you have you know what I'm going to
go ahead and charge you a dish uh rent
so every one of your dishes we're going
to need some money for those uh how many
computers you have up oh that's going to
that's going to going to C C we just
went to another did you hear that okay
yeah is it it's not making me want to
throw up anymore is it fix I God sorry
we just once again we're complete
[__] amateurs and we had to make a
little break in the podcast cuz that's
what makes this podcast so great because
our audio recording just got warped into
three different dimensions and we
started to hear our Echoes and we almost
threw up um I know it really is so yeah
no physically
disor is like right away cuz these are
like noise cancelling headphones so you
don't hear anything else but your own
echoed voice so it freaks you out she
she'll figure it out Peach you'll figure
it out um she a weirdo she's really
weird she's like Kermit except Kermit's
even weirder we were talking about how
you should have a you your computers
need to pay rent I was I was going to
say probably he would ask how many
sheets are on your bed and each one of
those sheets pays
rent oh I mean plus not not for nothing
I don't do people still say that not for
nothing is that a thing not for nothing
yeah yeah people say that it's really d
I don't know why I just said that but
not for nothing uh I looked it up on
Zillow which is like you know where you
see how much your house is worth and
then it gives you like a range estimate
of how much someone could in theory
charge you for rent and we're on the
high end of that scale man and like he
could be charging a lot less and still
be paying a mortgage on the house and
I'm like what the heck man like why why
are you doing this to me it's not like I
have a giant like you know German
Shepherd that's going to and it's a
puppy and it's going to eat all of your
[__] it's going to eat the hookups to
the washer and dryer no you learn very
quickly when you're in the the market to
rent that people can be very very shitty
just shitty yeah not good not good not
quality humans well the other lady that
you know is still always on the table as
an option we went and saw a place and
she was like all right good good and I'm
like okay should we you know maybe send
in an application
you can check her credit and all that
she walks over and grabs the forent sign
out of the ground throws it in the trash
can dumps the trash and says all right
you guys got it Go welcome to the
neighborhood we said we like the house
that's what we said it yeah it's nice uh
you know we should we can apply because
we've sort of I can't believe [__]
ripped that thing out of you got to
apply and they want to check your credit
so then if you want to be competitive
with anyone else that has an offer on
the table you know you can or you know
whatever racial profiling they want to
do that I don't it seems like unfair
doesn't it that she would just look at
the two of us and be like oh yeah
welcome to the neighborhood I'm like you
don't know who we are you know what I
mean like just it seems very sudden
should run people's credit scores you
know you should get an employment
history their income like all of that
like she it seemed wrong yeah yeah so
she she still is hoping for us to follow
through um but she's the solid play
she's all Plan B we we're already in the
neighborhood yeah oh my God I'm just
like I'm having such a weird time
finding a new place to live like we
we've only lived here for a year but
like you forget each year if you move
out my last place to live in for 2 years
the place before that I lived in like 3
years then the place before that I lived
in for like 5 years so if I like if I am
somewhere all I want to do is stay there
until I'm basically like there's no way
I can stay here anymore you know um
who is it pachy or she it's whatever
yeah yeah so I mean we could always live
there yeah it's always an option if if
this guy doesn't start to talk right act
right about his extra fees and [__] just
act right bro just act right you got to
learn how to act right man just be fair
seriously dude anyway we just hope that
that fig out we've just been talking to
yeah he's a name he's a name yeah we
don't even know his face well he works
for like a real estate company so it's
like a property management company
that's doing it uhhuh so it's
understandable yeah anyway in case you
guys haven't been able to tell this is
really taking its toll on us yeah I'm
exhausted yeah I haven't like been
Tweeting or doing anything fun on the
internet because we've literally we we
have made the scope of where we're
looking so giant you know what I mean
yeah um we're basically willing to live
anywhere that you can get to in a car
yeah and reasonable distance so
um so it's been very very difficult yeah
but we're we're we're seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel we just got to
find it now and get there get legs and
get oh my God I got to get so many legs
uh so yeah that's stressful that's our
life now pick up like I feel like a
hermit crab and I just like I I'm
getting out of my shell right now I got
to find another shell or else I'm going
to die from
exposure you won't die we'll be okay
what if what if whoever keeps me in ATT
didn't put a new shell in here for me to
move into did you ever do that did you
ever have hermit crabs did I ever have
hermit crabs no oh man me and my brother
had hermit crabs and uh so you know they
start off really little am I boring you
no no I was looking at Peach being an
idiot sorry I'm listening I wouldn't I
wouldn't be surprised if you just said
yes but oh no I'm interested in yes I'm
extremely bored by whatever you're about
to say um we you keep them in a tank
like a fish tank yeah but it's just
rocks at the bottom and uh hermit do you
know what hermit crab is yeah it's just
like this little crab and uh it's got a
little shell and all they do is
basically like poke their legs out
sometimes and like go get some water
maybe but if you see them while they're
awake it's like a
spectacle yeah they're not social
they're shell
creatures good joke Julian good you
they're not soal they're
Hermits
thanks I don't know why we would ever
get more than one it's not like they
even care about each other but anyways
so if your hermit crab was getting like
too big for a shell you know he couldn't
get his legs in there really good like
you could just tell he's sort of like H
I don't know where to be I'm too big for
my shell so you would go to the pet
store and you would buy a bigger shell
and then you'd put it in there and wait
for your hermit crab to switch shells
yeah and my brother and I we did this
many many times with all of our her
crabs that [__] pinched Us by the way
we didn't care um we would put a [__]
shell in there and then we would just
try and sit there for as long as
possible and we wanted to like dying to
see what the actual hermit crab looked
like you know there's no we can't go and
Google it we had dial up internet you
know using it for 15 minutes basically
all you got to do was
go yeah and your house couldn't get any
calls yeah and then yeah your house
can't get any calls by the time you
finally get on the internet your mom's
already yelling at you off of the
internet like we just it wasn't a thing
but I'm sure like now you could Google
what a hermit crab looks like without it
[__] shell on but it was like this
big giant mystery I can picture little
Devon and little Jenna just sitting and
waiting we were sitting there just like
staring at this tank and they do a lot
of it at night yeah which we learned the
hard way so we would sit there and stare
at my mom would be like guys got to go
to bed like time for bed we like Mom no
this was going to be the night mom that
we saw the her crab [__] come out and
switch shelves like we never even
thought about it that maybe the hermit
crab didn't want to come out of his
[__] shell cuz we sitting there
screaming and yelling at it like trying
to get it to [__] come out you know
tap it on the glass like little pieces
of [__] but then we'd wake up the next
morning and it would just be in its new
shell and be like man [__] [__] I mean
what's on the other side of those legs
it could be anything we don't know it's
just a crab but just a crab I mean we
thought maybe it had like 10 Les or
something like something cool it was
left up to your imagination is the point
like there was no telling what it could
have been but now you know what it's
like right have you Googled it not
recently but I did I'm pretty sure it's
just a little crab you know just looks
like a regular Little Crab but we
thought maybe it had this like tail that
wrapped all the way into the shell like
we just [__] didn't know you know
yeah no nothing it's nothing cool I
think that's cool I think that's a funny
little child story jet propeller system
in there maybe I was really he could
have just like a backpack full of like
food or something inside of the sh back
yeah like a backpack under the shell you
know keep the backpack safe you guys
anyone ever try to run with their
backpack it's so uncomfortable I've
tweeted that maybe 800 times oh really
oh yeah because I used to run home from
the bus station to watch TRL and watch
in sync and and it's like it's like each
each step it pulls you in One Direction
impossible and if you're running with a
backpack on you're automatically
attracting everyone's attention because
you shouldn't be running with a backpack
on we talked about this before no the
worst is when you're running with a
backpack down either up or downstairs so
if like you know what I mean no because
you're running so it's swaying you and
you're going in like a Direction that's
either up or down so it's either like
the worst in my opinion is running
downstairs with a backpack on cuz it's
like going up and sideways and you're
like CER of gravity is getting thrown
all over the place you have to use the
the handrail in that situation or else
you're asking for it yeah have you ever
fallen on your
backpack can I tell you can I tell you
when I used to fall on my backpack the
most like it happened regularly okay yes
no I'm not even kidding um in college I
used to follow my backpack almost every
single day in the winter but this is why
so I have these sneaker sandals I don't
think I've ever really shown them in in
videos oh I've seen them but I wore them
from sixth grade until I was uh 20 or
something years old 19 probably and no
they didn't still fit they I had you
know my toes had worn through the front
and they would actually touch the ground
but I didn't care and I would wear them
I don't know why I just like they were
my shoes you know and you know somebody
saw me on the street one day and then
asked my roommate was like is she all
right like does she need money for some
shoes or something like I just saw she
was just wearing the weirdest shoes ever
they're like no dude that's that's she
those are her sneaker I would wear them
to parties okay but after I stopped
wearing my sneaker sandals because I did
end up hurting my legs from walking from
like just having these horrific shoes um
I got a pair of Crocs and the tread on
the Crocs wears down so it just becomes
this like super slippery it's like when
you wearing bowling shoes and you cross
the line that's what it would have been
like yeah so I used to fall down on my
sneaker sandals a lot in the winter just
because there's no tread on those they
were just the worst shoes ever but then
when I got my Crocs if in the snow and
you trudge inside and your boots or
whatever all the ground everything's wet
you know what I mean they put those big
rugs in the front so you can try and
wipe your boots off but it's just
inevitable that some water is going to
get into the you know floor of your
school so I would have all of my
softball bags so I have like a giant bag
with my cleats and my outfit my v and
like all this stuff my gloves [__]
everything and uh then I have my schol
School backpack that was super heavy all
your [__] books and everything and um
I I was just so completely topheavy
because of all the things in my body and
noac mixed with the fact that I was
wearing basically just like banana peels
for shoes I would walk into the school
if ever there was any little yes and yes
to answer the question that you were
already thinking I was wearing Crocs
with socks in the middle of winter
because I couldn't wear my sneaker
sandals so what the [__] else am I going
to wear you know what I mean cuz you had
no other pair of shoes no I did I had
Moon boots they were giant boots but I
used to fall down in those just as much
also because they were just more of a
fashion statement okay um but I would
just like you know catch a little bit of
water on my Crocs and then just [__]
haul ass backwards like you I'd be like
off the ground because your backpack and
my softball bag were so heavy that I
used to wipe out constantly I don't
understand the logic behind this behind
what not ever fixing this situation I
didn't feel like it I don't know I don't
know you you know like how I am if I
like something I'm not going to stop
because must have been protective
because if it didn't if it made sense
would I be doing it no I only do things
that are just like a little bit
ridiculous can't argue with that after
hearing that story like I used to just
like [__] like my old roommate Jill
she would like we had all the same
classes cuz we were psych majors and you
know four or five four or five times out
of every 10 times we walked out of a
class I would slip and fall
sometimes all the way down most of the
time just slip and fall and almost fall
and then you know hit someone else and
she would just die laughing every single
day say the same thing why don't you get
new shoes I don't know man have you ever
put on Crocs with socks it's the most
comfortable thing in the world why would
I [__] wear anything else I guess
Comfort overall well I mean it didn't
help that there are holes in it and then
the snow gets in it yeah I was confused
by that you just you got to [__] if
you like what you like just wear what
you like yeah that's fair [__] everybody
else I went to high school with a kid
that didn't wear anything but Umbro
shorts until he was 21 years old that's
dedication uh if youer New York if you
guys are in high school and you're being
asked to put a quote for your yearbook
picture maybe if you like what you like
then wear what you like that's a good
candidate is it Jenna Mory said that
what was your what was your high school
you like what you like uh where what you
like what was mine yeah damn uh you know
I think I only had one because uh the
base it was for the baseball page I
don't think each person had a quote a
yeah that's so it was some baseball
related quote I can't remember I don't
know some some quote I can look it up
and share it for you guys on Twitter or
something but was it there's no crying
in baseball yes damn it got it don't
make fun of me I'm not I don't know what
it was um was it this was it Angels in
the Outfield no it was it was just this
oh was it your Kelling me
Smalls no oh
no don't guess anymore they're baseball
movies not from a baseball movie you
said it was a baseball quote I said it
was baseball that doesn't me from a
baseball movie it was a baseball quote
meaning that I used it in the context of
baseball not just in the context of my
face in the
yearbook I don't think it'd be like it
is but it do that was the quote what the
[__] is that I think that's how it goes
are you serious no no no it's not my
quote oh my God I don't even know you
that's not even English it was roses are
red violets are blue I don't think it'd
be like it is but it
do play as
Ville we've already entered into the
realm of ridiculous no I see I I
sometimes look back on my high school
senior quote and I think that I really
dro the ball you know what I mean cuz
there's so much room there to just crush
it yeah like uh there were a couple
twins in my high school and so there
quote one of them was like you know nice
and funny or whatever and the other one
was just an arrow that said I'm was
stupid that's funny that's Forward
Thinking right there that's knowing your
pictures how do they know which one was
going to be on the right and the left
one was like Justin and one was like
Jason so that's Jason so Jason's on the
left so Justin had I'm with stupid one
of I don't can we verify that it's I
don't my your book's over there but I'm
sure you can I'm kiding I'm kidding it's
going to be verified
later
no uh I was thinking that I should
have if I had a chance to do it over
roses are red violets are blue no no no
roses are gray violets are gray
everything's gray I'm a
dog that's really good that's really
good I know you're right there were so
many opportunities to crush it with that
blew it blew it well if you guys ever
need uh senior quotes cuz you might be
approaching that time in your life then
yeah use good quotes and crush it so you
can look back and be proud of your
decision not wish you had made a better
one yeah but the worst is when somebody
does a quote that is like no longer
funny you know what I mean don't use
anything too
topical yeah like I would I would not
have liked it if I had made like a a
Sarah Palin joke reference you know it's
no longer relevant doesn't live on it
needs to stand the test of time yeah
although I think roses are gray violets
are gray everything's gray I'm a dog is
pretty time it's really funny it's a
really funny
quote Yeah that that's that's something
you can always you can tell your
grandkids or like a really stupid joke
like if you're a stoner in your school
how do fish get
high
seaweed I'm slow blinking into the mic
Simon Rex said that the other day on
Instagram Dirt
Nasty it's funny yeah
that is funny do you know what your
quote would be if you could redo it I
already told you what roses are red
violets are blue I don't think it'd be
like it is but it do no come on that's a
bad example it's not
Timeless okay how about since you're
looking for Timeless I about I just
write rayb
bands oh my God that's sort of an inside
joke why don't you explain that yeah so
we were in uh it was in Bali right uh we
were with Rome uh Jenna's assistant and
and we were in the store we were just
shopping at these like cheap little
shops looking for whatever and somehow
the topic of rayb bands come up and R
said to me Ray bands are Timeless and I
said what I say if if a person says to
you Ray bands are Timeless that person
is a hipster she got so upset and she
may be right because I guess are kind of
Timeless but I just uh I made fun of her
and I tweeted that out and uh it's
really funny because um Rome hates
getting called that
no I don't I just I just thought it was
funny because that's like the way that
for any of you that watch the podcast
with Brett the way his mom called Bruno
Mars the most incredible Entertainer
Entertainer performer yeah something
like that something the what what was
the language that made it so powerful
and impactful the ultimate showman the
ultimate showman yeah that's like that
sentence by saying rayb bands are
Timeless you're saying no no no I yes
directly correlated no I I feel like I
could think of 700 other things that
might be considered Timeless before Ray
bands it's like when you say Bruno Mars
is the ultimate showman I'm pretty sure
I can think of 35 other showman that are
way more ultimate not as not as ultimate
as Bruno
Mars yes I hear exactly what you're
saying anyway I think I got nothing
against Bruno Mars but I mean like the
ultimate showman hey I'm at Brett's mom
and she uh is a bright lady and I'm sure
she just wasn't thinking straight when
she said
that no I think she just really really
likes Bruno Mars the ultimate what
showman the Bruno Mars concert in I mean
if you love somebody then just fullblown
love them you know yeah you speak
irrationally when you're talking about
like your favorite athletes or per
performers or singers you tell them
everyone that they're the best because
you love them so much yeah I that when I
got tickets to see Rihanna like I love
Rihanna I Love Rihanna but you know when
I saw her in concert I mean there's lots
of fire and lights and stuff and
happening w i mean if we're being
rational here it's not like she put on a
Beyonce concert you know what I mean
it's not like she put on a [__]
Michael Jackson concert she sort of to
stepped around and like grabbed her
boobs and like shook her butt and and
then you know she sang some songs and
then we all went home yeah it was not
like the most life-changing experience
but when I left that concert I was like
it was the best thing
ever cuz you love her so much right
exactly yeah well there you go it allows
you to think it allows you to stretch
the reality yeah
yeah I'm like she walked towards us one
time and like you know she like she
squatted a
little and then she said rude boy you
yeah oh man you do love Rihanna I do rwi
Riri woo did you just call her rwi Riri
woo rwi peew RI
rii
rewe
no I will
not I will not
rewi what good language thanks good
words we've delved into craziness yeah
um also but right before we ate dinner
uh I was feeding my need for uh I don't
know what you would call it conspiracy
theories I'm consumed by a lot of this a
lot of times I I have a hard time
understanding how people don't get
consumed with things like that like I'm
obsessed with Ancient Aliens I'm
obsessed with like anything that has to
do with outer space or like the
government like [__] I just like to
know if there's a conspiracy Theory what
someone thinks so that I can think about
it and absorb it and then see if I agree
with it or not mhm you know what I mean
yeah yeah but I was watching a 12p part
video series about someone talking about
you know basically how a doomsday prep
with uh Abola becoming sort of a
Forefront of a lot of people's
concerns like what's the death toll at
this
point I don't know K stop licking me
honey I don't know I mean it's it's just
a very scary thing and you know the news
media outlets and whatever are saying
that you can only get it through bodily
fluids and contacts but there's been uh
a news reporter like a cameraman that
contracted it without having any close
contact with anyone and I guess they
have you know proven or thought that
it's can be carried like someone sneezes
it can ride on like water air Mo
molecules I don't know I don't want to
get too far into it because all I did
was listen to someone else talk about it
so I am no by no means an expert but it
is a scary idea do you know what I mean
AB the idea of a pandemic yeah and to
think about how the government plays a
role in it you actively helping it kind
of spread but basically to get to the
point of what I wanted to say was when
you when sometimes when I get consumed
with like these thoughts and I'm like
listening to someone talk about it for
long enough I'm like I need to go off
the grid like you know 2012 man I'm just
going to drive as far away as I can like
what are you doing she's got to go out
can I let her out yeah go
ahead time out I'm L hey I feel like
once I start going down a rabbit hole of
conspiracy theories I'm like you know
what I got to do man is they got to get
a ranch and I got to build a bunch of
Gardens and like get a bunch of guns
build a
fortress fill the entire outside with
treadmills so the zombies can't get in
yes patented yeah you know what I mean
yeah like oh man dude we can't go to the
doctor they're [__] there are a bunch
of I don't know it's a bad word
communist you know what I mean like once
you go too far down the black hole of
the internet suddenly your thinking
really starts to align with it like man
I got to get a [__] RV and I'm just
going to drive it up a mountain and just
sit there yeah until the day I die then
you become part of the craziness well
it's but I mean a lot of what some of
the more extreme people have to say
aren't bad things you know it's to be
prepared take care of your immune system
you know be as prepared as you can in
your location if you had a place that
you could get away then you know if
things started to become serious you can
always get away but for a lot of people
that's not an option like I don't have a
[__] safe house with a big Garden
filled with [__] doomsday supplies
bro um but you know having a a plan to
survive something ever did happen when
uh there was an earthquake like
basically right where we lived yeah and
um we realized that we didn't have any
[__] like big jugs of water or like
more than a week's worth of food in the
house you know what I mean and it really
starts to make you think like if
something ever really did happen and you
can't do anything really a lot of people
are ill prepared because we're so sort
of dependent on the way that the world
is yeah and you never think that could
actually happen
yeah cuz we're just we like to live in
la la land we're in a world culture of
distraction yeah yeah you know and it's
also not happening on our front
doorsteps yeah so it's then you know out
of say it out of mind a little bit right
yeah but yeah I was going way too far
down the rabbit hole and it was very
difficult for me cuz I went straight
from like stressing about dealing with
this negotiation of the rent today and
then you know all it took for me was
like oh what's that article and then I'm
like full-blown Rabbit Hole yeah it
doesn't take long yeah I made my day
like 20 times more stressful by just
listening to this guy talk about it yeah
you know he he wasn't sugarcoating
anything so it was kind of stressful to
listen to well yeah but I I just like
I've heard a lot of people talk YouTube
videos are like writing articles like
their thoughts on religion on aliens on
government on [__] anything you can
think of sink holes and noise like watch
UFOs military coverups of UFOs like I'm
obsessed with that that [__] and like I
like to know what exists in terms of
ideas but whether or not I choose to
absorb it I feel like takes a couple
days because for the first couple days
I'm like man letting it marinate that
was [__] crazy I like to get my mind
blown on a regular basis yeah sometimes
it's bad today was not fun no today was
bad needed in this in this moment in
time but it's over now you you kind of
calm down you're not looking on Zillow
for have I places in Montana as a safe
house oh man I want to go to a safe
house in
Montana somebody [__] in Montana
build me a safe house man I'll come
there and [__] live with
you I mean it's not a bad plan that is
sort of my ultimate goal I don't want to
be I want to be somewhere that's Oregon
what
Oregon it's close to two cities though
yeah I don't want to go to Oregon I want
to go somewhere where you're like ah I
have to drive 20 minutes to go [__]
get some orange juice that's what I want
you know yeah it'd be really fun like I
like big bear I want to live in Big Bear
yeah Big Bear is nice I like it I don't
know if I would want to live there but I
like it why not big bears in California
by the way you go absolutely CRA why
because there's nothing to do really
yeah you've you've been there you know
that I don't think so I think I'd be
happy you okay I disagree I think you'd
be completely unhappy living there
full-time mhm we had you wanted any of
any sort of nightlife experience you
don't have any no but I feel like you
check all of your baggage at the door
when you move to a place like that okay
yeah so but I'm saying right now no you
don't want to live in Big Bear okay fine
yeah I don't but I'm saying someday I
would like to cuz it' be [__] awesome
yeah cuz I don't want to do [__]
anything except be like haha no people
yeah no it it does see it does sound
nice that fantasy of like being nowhere
not woring why are you crying kmit get
out of here dude I'll have to walk like
10 minutes to my neighbor's house to go
knock on the door and be like you guys
want to come over play some games what
are you guys doing we got electricity
over here you want to come hang out yeah
no I know I'll make friends with my
neighbors and then I'll hook up like a
tin can with a big string in the middle
of it be like hey hey neighbors hey hey
neighbors what are you doing what are
you guys doing sounds like the life yeah
but it doesn't matter if they're really
old too yeah why don't you close that
door she's it back in here no I don't
want to get up again I'm it's fine
that's not what the noise is the noise
is the
AC no I know that but it's just [__]
hold on I'm going to close the
door talk to the podcast about
what
um the Montana idea is is definitely
something that's comforting to think
about like a cozy you know cabin style
house that you'd live in and move away
to and never have
to uh worry about other things and being
in the city and traffic and [__] like
that
um and yeah as a part-time thing like
you know we go to Big Bear sometimes
it's nice to get away and do that just
right now you know I mean aside from all
the talk of leaving for a safe house uh
it just doesn't seem like it's in the
cards right now that's not to say it's
not the right it's not going to happen
right now it's a complete like pipe
dream for the time being but you also
seem to forget that I'm from the middle
of [__] nowhere you know what I mean
like I moved to Boston and then I moved
to Los Angeles because I come from sort
of just like you guys want to go [__]
party in a field tonight and like you
know stare at each other is somebody
going to bring a trash bin so we can
make a fire in it like you know what I
mean like there's really not a lot to do
but that's also very comforting to me
because that's what home feels like do
know what I mean no that's fair like the
middle of nowhere you couldn't middle of
nowhere me hard enough in order for me
to feel like man we're in the wilderness
unless you really were in the wilderness
no I hear you you were born and Brad it
yeah
yeah it's fun yeah I know it's not that
bad
I know in hindsight at the time when
you're an angsty teenager it's literally
the worst environment ever yeah cuz it's
you and nothing else and know you're
like God Mom why can't we grow up in New
York City like all the cool cats are
their cool clothes and they can do
anything that they want their parents so
I can let them do fun stuff they take
trains mom trains have you ever seen a
train we don't have any
trains you know what I mean yeah
yeah
where where would you want to
live I I guess I I don't know all those
all those um States kind of just blend
together for me I don't well like
Wyoming Montana like I don't know any of
them they're awesome been to Oregon
Oregon's awesome I like Oregon uh yeah I
don't know but you know I'd like to go
to those places I'd like to go to one of
those States and see what it's like um
yeah I haven't really been to those you
know middle of America well I mean that
sort of like middle of nowhere houses
and stuff and parts of not all of it not
all of it's like it at all but like
parts of Montana Wyoming Idaho like you
can get pretty remote in any state but
in those States in particular there's a
lot of places where you know you're just
not very close other people and the
population's low the state's big uh what
was it going to say it's F it's awesome
and it also sort of naturally lends
itself to you being more self-reliant as
opposed to those of us that live in
populated cities where you can sort of
have anything that you want all the time
you know what I mean like living in that
style as it is is sort of a leg up on
anybody if there ever was some sort of
awful disaster where you're already
pretty self-reliant because I mean what
are you going to do [__] drive 45
minutes to go to a store every day no
hell no like like I'm going to go one
time then I'm going to need a bunch of
[__] [__] and I'm just going to live
here for a while you know what I mean
you're not driving in and out of town
self-reliant is a good way to put it
yeah yeah whereas you're learning to
survive alone and be with you know the
people you're with but then not rely on
everything all the surround maybe see
your neighbors and stuff but like if you
if you want fresh food or whatever A lot
of them just [__] grow in their
backyard whereas many of us that live in
big cities we rent a place it's not like
I can just pop up a [__] crop of food
over here you know yeah yeah like
somebody's going to get real pissed and
it's going to cost me a pretty [__]
penny when I move out of this [__] my
security deposit yeah um but yeah it's a
it's a lot more self-reliant which I'm
envious of at times yeah because I think
it'd be really nice to wake up every day
and just [__] get really caffeinated
and then go ham on a garden gardening
can be fun man am I aging myself yet I
think you're aging
[Laughter]
everyone I just think it would be really
fun and then someday yeah and then you
know I mean the the worst part about
that is
that no no no bad
parts all right Jenna you closed that
argument very well good argument Jenna
thanks Jenna you're welcome Jenna good
work good tolerating Julian thanks
Julian a I'm just kidding I'm sorry for
boring I kid I
kid I kid God Peach you're gulping yeah
and carment in the egies are taking over
the house all right Marvel get down no
dogs allow to sit on the lap it's going
to make you guys all jealous of each
other these yeah yeah where so you
really have no like perfect place you
would want to live no I don't know man
comment in the comments of this video if
there's a perfect place that you would
want to live yeah and why about Ireland
I love Ireland Ireland feel like I might
get a little sad if I move there forever
though why because you're not in your
family well I don't know I feel like um
I think I I I like the weather there but
I feel like anyone who lives in the
weather like that constantly like in
Seattle like Rochester it's just [__]
overcast it gets very depressing
yeah you're getting tugged on and I'm
from no tugging uh yeah no but I love
Ireland I don't know though like in
terms of living and being there I mean I
know places I want to travel I feel like
I'm too young to know where I want to
just live forever you know what I mean I
want to I want to see the middle of
America I want to see these states that
I've never been to if I could ever get
back to Ireland that would be incredible
um but yeah I don't know you've been to
Greece haven't you I've been to yeah
I've been well I've been to cyp tell us
about Greece Julian would you ever live
in Greece uh I don't know I was too
young I don't really remember much did
you eat olives though no I ate Euros
those are good a what the Euro the you
know pea thing with hero yeah that's how
it's spelled but it's pronounced y r o
yeah it's not proun that way it's
pronounced
gyro yeah um oh uh Greek food's great I
love Greek food that was before you knew
you were Celia I was a kid yep a so it
was bad and good I got to eat all the
food but now I can't did you eat any
feta I don't remember babe yeah but did
did you eat any lamb yes that was the
first time I ever ate lamb on a boat you
ate lamb on a boat yeah I was like this
little who are you Barbara sty sounds
like the lapa luxury I'm kidding I don't
think I've ever tried
lamb no I have okay Lamb's good you've
had it with me right now yeah why lap of
luxury you don't even know the story I
was kid I was spear fishing on this
teeny little Robbo and they brought lamb
we were spear fishing that sounds
incredible yeah it was incredible I was
really lucky I got to go once in a
lifetime opportunity to get fed one
animal while you're spearing another hey
come on kidding it was a joke all right
it sounded funny you said I ate lamb on
a
boat I just making a joke boats and hoes
sometimes jokes don't make any sense I
asked you if you were Barbara strand
okay I'm not I know you're not I'm
not wait so you you were spear fishing
yeah we [__] I spear fished a face
face off of a fish I spear fished it in
half that's barbaric oh my God spear
fishing is one of the most visceral fun
things I've ever done you're underwater
with your mask and you got a gun with a
[__] long ass spear attached to it
and you just [__] fire and it shoots
and it's attached to a string and you
try to kill fish and then you eat them
but my the fish I I killed didn't it was
first of all it wasn't big enough to eat
and second of all I didn't keep it it
just like fell apart oh my God yeah I
have a vivid image in my mind of what
that looked like when I chopped his face
off oh my God see see this is why if
there was a zombie apocalypse or some
sort of Apocalypse I I think that I
wouldn't survive because I just don't
have well if you're with me we got the
treadmills going we're fine we don't
even need to worry about yeah but I mean
you see me I have a hard time killing a
bug without feeling like responsible
horrible person in the whole
world yeah I can't hunt man I just can't
do it you don't like guns you don't like
any of that it's fine I like to fish but
I always throw them back cuz I don't eat
fish either yeah if you ate fish do you
think you would fish our friends now
food what if you ate fish do you think
you would like fishing and keeping the
fish and eating them I don't know I like
cheeseburgers but I don't like killing
the cheeseburger animal
okay I don't know it
just it makes me sad yeah but I also
don't eat a lot of meat so I feel a
little better you should you're not
you're not contributing that much to the
cause to the cause of killing animals
yeah yeah you're you're staying you know
you're basically Che me though oh when
is Che me how many days Che me is
Sundays so we got six days so we had it
yesterday six days I can eat the meat I
want it right now she me cheeseburgers
we should do uh on one of the Sundays we
should just see how many we can eat oh I
couldn't even eat one uh halfway through
I've eaten like four or
five and then I felt dead the rest of
the week I know it's rough it is rough
but it's worth it have you ever been
hunting um no not really I don't think
I've ever hunted I don't have any means
to do that like I don't have people who
I would hunt with or at Cornell my
brother went to college he [__] had
to take like a gym class or whatever and
he took archery and uh he's certified to
hunt and kill with a bowan arrow in the
state of New York yeah I'm not as badass
as him so [__] badass isn't it cool
yeah
I'd love to I'd love to hunt sometime
I've shot guns before but never had any
training or anything I've just gone to
the range shooting guns uh but I I would
love to learn archery I'd love to go
hunting those these are the types of
things that I would feel like would
become Hobbies if I moved to a place
like
Montana yeah I just get nervous like a
there were a lot of people uh that I
knew growing up that you know their
parents would have guns and that sort of
thing but they always kept them in a gun
safe but even still like every kid was
like oh I know the code to it yeah no
dude you're scary as it
is dude you're a scary dude please don't
be scary yeah just do the right thing
man don't be
scary yeah don't be scary just don't be
scary don't be scary and have a firearm
in your hand please don't be scary use
it for when you're in the woods man you
know what I mean
yeah you if you if you lived in the
middle of nowhere what do you think your
life would be
like uh well and like like Montana or
something like that yeah somewhere like
deep [__] who gives a [__] town I
probably uh I mean like who like I can
do whatever the [__] I want Town how old
am I let's say you're middleaged let's
say you have like a Gray beard like so
my 40s yeah and you wear flannel I can
wear flannel now no you can't only in
this vivid imagination can you wear flan
I would grow giant beard like a like a
lumberjack beard I already gave you a in
this go to work chopping wood like a
lumberjack this sounds like the
beginning of softcore
porn and then after work uh I W I would
not go take off my clothes I would go
take my gun and kill some dinner whoa
and then I'd bring it back home and cook
it uh what would you kill like a rabbit
deer probably you kill a whole deer
right before dinner yeah red did it
you'd get it all ready yeah I mean i'
I'd YouTube how to do it oh my God but
in this in this in this fantasy I mean
I'm I'm the all knowing like Lumberjack
American guy who knows how to kill and
shoot and prepare a dinner so oh my God
uh what else [__] insane to me do you
know how much blood comes out of a deer
when you like [__] no but I would
know at this point like the the in rooms
where they you know hunt and then kill
and then they prepare the meat or
whatever and skin it and all that like
there's drains in the floor oh yeah I
believe that there's tons of blood in
the body or something that big I don't
like it makes me scared I would also
pick up some spinach for you to eat oh
thanks you're welcome I like the
spinach yeah it has no central nervous
system um then what then what would you
do I don't know i' go uh play bridge you
would no I'm not not indie I'm Community
Center yeah I uh what what do people do
I mean I don't know would you make a
fire
yeah
probably probably make a fire would you
I really like this so okay then would
you sit in front of your big window and
look out at the mountains no it's too
dark it gets dark really early oh well
what would you do once it got dark um i'
clean my gun oh my God I don't know man
what would you play solitaire no that
means I'm alone would you read a book am
I alone in this no I can be there you
can be there sure no it's up to you I
don't I don't want to trouble you hey
come on I probably yeah I I don't know
why I'm answering these questions I was
just
like Julian don't want to play along I
don't want to play because I feel like
it's super arbitrary and it's just kind
of random answering these questions you
know what I would
do
H what would you do sorry I'm sorry you
fed arbit you do it's like my my life
that's what I want to think about I feel
like I would wake up up get really
caffeinated it's like super early and
then I would go let all the chickens out
so they could be free range like Bella
does in Utopia yeah she got voted off or
no I don't [__] know man I can't
[__] find the show anymore yeah we
got to watch it whatever uh yeah let all
my chickens out and then I would go into
the barn and be like hey barn animals
and I would brush them and like talk to
him and feed him see would spend time
with the animals yeah and then uh I
would get on one and ride it around okay
and then I would build a life-size
replica of the American Ninja Warrior uh
thing and just become an American Ninja
Warrior and you would go to Venice every
Ian duh and then I would be the best
American ninja warrior ever and then I
win half million bones what do you do
with half million bones never mind just
Ponder I would build another life-size
American I think that's going to
it I think we've come more than full
circle today oh sorry Julian why are you
so sad I'm not sad what's the matter
nothing's the matter I'm fine I'm just
I'm kind of good on this this this whole
podcast what on the whole podcast
tonight tonight's podcast okay I'm sorry
you're so sad that we were talking about
American Ninja Warrior and I'm good
fishing and hunting all right and don't
be sorry it was fun doomsday yeah well
don't get sick everyone don't don't get
Ebola hopefully no one has Ebola that's
watching this and um we'll be back next
week with another podcast hopefully not
as late as this one we'll try to get it
done earlier and we may or may not be in
this house fingers crossed fingers
crossed we'll be in a different place
so [__] yeah yeah thank you guys for
listening and hanging
out is that the music that's coming in
yeah Jenna likes that ending music that
I put yeah what about that music huh
that
music uh follow us on all things
subscribe we're on iTunes see you next
week bye later Kermit all right do need
to hug God
[Music]
baby